goudreau bonjour bonjour écrivain
travailleur social slameur musiciens
conteurs bout comme aux non je refuse un
musicien conteur non je compte très peu
et je ne joue pas de musique je
m'intéresse beaucoup à la musique j'aime
collaborer des musiciens mais en fait
moi j'écris parfois je le dis sur scène
parfois d'autres le chante parfois je le
publie c'est vraiment l'écriture le
coeur de ma vie moi mais vous avez un
rythme fou dans la trilogie de la bête
ont juré que vous en faites justement de
la musique en tout cas vous en écouter
beaucoup parce que le rythme ça se lit
comme une pièce musicale à ce
commentaire là on me le fait quelques
années ça me dérangeait ménagement
atteint comme un compliment parce que
c'est un choix mais je l'entends comme
ça merci de la sauver mais au début ça
me dérangeait pas ce qu'on me dit ah ça
paraît que tu as fait du rab l'islam y
un côté très près de la réalité c'est
ses ennemis puis moi je déroule mais
c'est vraiment un roman russe point
projet de réalité pour moi c'est
important d'avoir des livres qui se
tiennent en dehors de l'univers poétique
ou scéniques et finalement je comprends
que oui celle que mais que finalement
tout comme unique et peut se nourrir de
façon hostile entre je parlais de la
trilogie si ce qui vous a propulsé
ailleurs est-ce que vous êtes encore
propulsée par ce grand succès là il ya
eu un autre qu'yves après mes jeux
cette trilogie leur vous a défini en
tout cas dans le regard de beaucoup de
gens ici ailleurs oui absolument la bête
c'est une belle surprise dans ma vie car
et main mais je veux pas rester près que
ce personnage l'autre ma carrière donc
trois rames en trois ans et on passe à
autre chose
et j'avais déjà leur matamore à moi qui
me battait à ce moment là le qui m'a
demandé plus de travail qui est un peu
plus ambition de vous de la structure
donc je me suis lancé dans cette
trilogie le camp des armes
et depuis oui c'est probablement ma
principale carte de vie
les gens me connaissent beaucoup par la
bête puis après viens de voir le
spectacle s'intéresse aux albums mais
oui c'est la bad qui m'a mis au monde et
ce qui est fascinant dans ces trois
romans là où ce grand roman là c'est la
pulsion de vie qui l'homme aime quand ça
va très mal mais pas un peu mal très mal
quand nos parents sont absents quand on
a tout ce qui peut aller mal vont mal
mais il ya encore ce désir là de vivre
et vous êtes intéressé beaucoup aux gens
plus poké ou s'il ya un lien évident oui
oui enfin moi j'ai fait un grand détour
par le travail social on croit qu'un
travailleur social qui m'a écrit mais
moi je voulais être écrivain à la base
mais on m'a dit ah commence par
travailler puis après tu donc j'ai fait
un grand détour par le travail social et
je me suis fait prendre au jeu parce que
j'ai adoré ça et effectivement mon
intérêt pour les gens qui sont un peu
dans la marge très dans la marge est
grand et les sincère j'ai l'impression
d'être un peu aussi pourquoi les romains
fonctionne bien c'est con ça malgré ton
regard bienveillant je mets beaucoup
d'humour noir dans des situations
parfois très durs très trash mais malgré
tout il ya une réelle
il ya un réel désir de rendre ces
gens-là acceptable pour la littérature
acceptable pour les arts dire s'il
existe au parc émilie gamelin et ils ont
droit d'exister aussi dans notre
littérature et ils peuvent à être ce
qu'ils sont c'est à dire des gens qui
parfois vont avoir très longtemps c'est
parfois vont prendre de très mauvaises
décisions mais aussi des personnes qui
peuvent à être brillante qui peuvent
avoir des talents qui peuvent rebondir
quand on les attend plus qu'ils peuvent
faire preuve de résilience même c'est
devant n'ont jamais eu dans leur vie et
qu'ils peuvent aussi s'acharner dans la
non résilience et en crever comme en mer
des centaines et des milliers chaque
année au québec
et ces gens là cette pandémie là les au
toucher encore plus
absolument on oublie que les personnes
qui étaient déjà isolé en d'être
avant la pandémie sont encore plus isolé
est probablement encore plus en détresse
et il y en a une grande part qu'on
voyait pas du tout et qu'on voit encore
moins et à ces personnes là sont à
apposer une bonne action pour le temps
des fêtes moi je propose à tout le monde
de se demander c'est qu'il plus potier
dans mon réseau est qui qui était le
plus isolé c'est qui qu'a eu plus de
difficulté peu importe l'équipe que ce
soit des troubles de santé mentale des
problèmes de consommation juste d
isolement social
cette difficulté est en relation prendre
des nouvelles je pense que ce serait le
cadeau humanitaire qu'on ne leur laisse
pas le jeu c'est une personne ne peut
pas consacrer la prime jeunesse ça peut
être un cousin ça peut être un ami de
qui on ne peut une nouvelle depuis
longtemps mais on a tous dans nos
réseaux des personnes plus ou moins
hypothéquée et prendre de leurs
nouvelles tout simplement préfère une
immense différence
j'ai vu en prévention suicide des
situations incroyables où des gens m'ont
dit un inconnu qui me sourit sur la rue
le commis du dépanneur qui est vu que
j'avais les larmes aux yeux qui m'a
demandé comment j'allais des fois ça m'a
donné une journée de plus pour ne pas
passer à l'acte est finalement allé
chercher de la haine dans un centre de
prévention suicide dans l'intervalle un
point pas des fois il faut pas grand
chose pour donner du sens à la vie de
quelqu'un et vous impliquer mouvement
santé mentale du québec justement si
pour vous je le dire la crosse montre
que c'est la zone où vous voulez faire
votre petite différence ou et puis le
moment sentimentale québec ce qui est
intéressant en particulier ce qu'on
présente pas les troubles de santé
mentale comme la principale mission
c'est à dire ce qu'on veut c'est
vraiment faire de la prévention
évidemment mais aussi de la
sensibilisation fait que on a tous une
santé mentale comme on a tous une santé
physique et la santé physique depuis
quelques années on s'en occupe puis peu
à peu près il ya des gènes et des
protéines on en parlait d émission des
genres théâtre santé physique le tout c
est en a trois qui 30 40 ans tout le
monde fumait une barrière bon sens qui
l'emporté mais on est reine
- de ça avec la santé mentale à une
révolution à faire encore il y une
révolution enfin effectivement et tous
les moyens sont bons
donc d'en parler de dire comment est ce
qu'on prend soin de souhaits ce qu'on en
ait conscience qu'on le fait
régulièrement puis moi je peux un modèle
la dame et ça m'intéresse beaucoup et
puis j'essaie d'installer des choses
dans ma vie pour le faire et à chacun de
trouver ses moyens et en a pour qui la
méditation ça va être magnifique mois la
méditation ça m'énerve
j'aurais prendre des marches dans le
bois mon ami qui est en chaise roulante
peut pas les prendre des marches dans le
bourg donc lui va faire quoi s'étaient
questionnés lettres super c'est
d'installer des choses dans nos vies qui
nous aide à prendre soin de nous mêmes
et nos proches connaître les ressources
professionnelles connaître ses propres
ressources personnelles il ya plein
moyen assez simple qu'on peut utiliser
pour prendre soin de sa tête
et comme moyen ce qui est vraiment
intéressant à votre démarche que vous
dis sacralisé long et à la grande
bibliothèque
mais vous désacraliser la littérature la
poésie puis vous dites ça c'est pas vrai
que c'est pas accessible puis on peut
jouer avec ce jouet avec le mont les
faire lire les faire écrire même ça
c'est une arme qui peut être très forte
la littérature les lives la poésie la
littérature fait plus pour l'humanité
que la plupart des gouvernements
sachons le et il n'y a rien de tel que
de grands poètes de grandes écrivaines
pour une nation pour s'inscrire dans le
monde et perdure et faire perdurer sa
culture dans certains points et moi je
suis loin d'être un expert en
littérature moi je suis profondément
amoureux de la chose vie je ne suis pas
de ceux qui croient que c'est bon pour
tout le monde sait qu'avec des gens qui
aiment pas la littérature s'en vont très
bien mais on est tellement mis en
contact entre autres à l'école avec le
sport assez peu avec les enr et encore
moins avec une littérature qui nous
interpelle personnellement ton enfance
la littérature dans gorge des déjà dans
leur fait
découvrez des hauteurs de force et moi
ce que j'essaie de dire c'est juste
essayer d'en découvrir par vous même
il n'y a pas de mauvaises lectures il
nous apparaît génial qui se font dans le
fantastique dans l'horreur dans la bande
dessinée
soyez curieux il ya tellement de bons
livres y en a un fait pour vous trouver
le sait quoi la réponse que les gens
sont étonnés parce que vous avez
constaté des découvertes j'ai souvent
bah oui des découvertes mais ce qui
étonne le plus les gens d'aller dans les
conférences les ateliers sur toutes vos
bd atelier quand ils écrivent leurs
mains mais qu'il se découvre un talent
et qu'il ya toujours une pépite à
quelques pas mal texte pas toujours
génial au complet il ya toujours une
phrase ou un verre qui les attendent
ah oui ça c'est intéressant je pourrais
travailler seul mais oui tu pourrais
retravailler ce parce qu'en vingt
minutes avec des néons dessus de la tête
dans un contexte qui ne favorise pas du
tout l'introspection la création de
réussi à écrire quelque chose
d'intéressant imagine ce repreneur deux
ans pour se mettre en condition pour
plonger en toi-même peut aller chercher
cette matière ça doit marcher parce que
vous les regardez pas d'euro ce monde là
aussi et puis vous respectez la
différence puis vous n'êtes pas si vous
êtes tout sauf ce noble pays je pense
que si les gens avec qui vous parlez de
ce doivent le sentir et se sentir libéré
dont qui est capable d'être humaine ben
j'espère puis en même temps il lui
militaire est assez facile parce que mon
chat impressionné pour vrai encore
j'essaie dé préserver sa cage maintenant
dans les classes dans les écoles puis
souvent de jouer les professeurs ceux
qui réagissent mais bon j'ai encore à
apprendre je considère pas or écrit mon
maillot texte encore pour moi la bête
c'est pas mon chat d'oeuvre puis à
tamara moi que je considère comme ayant
déjà d'elle non plus
il reste encore beaucoup de choses à
écrire plus beaucoup de choses à
apprendre c'est pas une posture que je
me donne il ya vraiment j'ai
l'impression tout inventer encore mais
est ce que vous êtes en train d'écrire
un autre roman lol le juge vient
terminer un premier livre jeunesse qui
devrait paraître au printemps aux
éditions 2 et juan vous enfin vous êtes
écrivain c'est exactement pour ça et ce
sont les personnes presque au personnage
du livre mes enfants et oui la première
raison c'est pour leur expliquer quelque
chose de notre vie qui se passe en ce
moment donc c'est vraiment mon public
cible ses deux enfants les miens on va
quand même en imprimer quelques milliers
ou coup on a rejoindrait d'autres mais
ça s'adresse vers les enfants et sinon
j'ai d'autres romans en chantier mais
trop ma wii qui deviendront probablement
un roman je travaille souvent comme ça
j'ai plus à l'histoire et un certain
pouvoir envers joie je récupère
bellemans que c'est fini par dominer
rios à david goudreault le nouveau
matériel cd ou vous cela mais où vous
déclara mais des textes
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant vous dites
je veux pas les publier les textes c'est
fait pour être écoutés avec la musique
c'est un gros problème en ce moment je
dois gérer beaucoup de satisfaction les
gens veulent les textes et je les
comprends pas c'est que rec en même
temps j'ai quatre à manger trois
recueils vous pouvez venir en masse ça a
été écrit pour être dite pour moi c'est
pas la même chose écrire un texte quand
il doit être entendu quand elle doit
être lu donc une affirmation
effectivement avec cet album étoiles
particulière pour battre mon coeur s'est
un peu élevé mais c'est beau merci je
devrais monté sur con
une scène écrire encore combien de
livres pour me sentir vivre me donnait
le droit d'être d'être à part entière
entier assumer nico aime mes envies tout
faire péter
mais révoltée contre chaque rêve révolue
brin terme et magne en absolu et que les
mâts seule vérité c'est un long silence
écoute mon coeur battre
avril qui est la filiation
parlez à votre fils tout le monde se
trompe souvent une personne n'est
meilleur que l'autre
mon et j'espère
embrasse la terre
à mazda cohérence et ne te découvre pas
d'un fil
il contredit ventricules ozawa garde les
électeurs ne compte qu'un de 10 q est ce
curieux enthousiastes à lui mais fébrile
et du monde
jusqu'au au moins dans
ne te découvre pas d'un fil monfils à 7
un texte qui finalement le jeu est
adressé à l'attention de mon fils mais
mais dans lequel je me parle beaucoup
aussi en cours de route parce que pour
moi c'est un défi incroyable je pense
pour chacun de devenir soi même de
réussir à briser tous que les pressions
sociales puisque l'éducation tout ce qui
qui finalement nous mais cette espèce de
carcan dans lequel on croit devoir être
alors que j'ai l'impression que dès
qu'on fait craquer sont un peu on est
tellement mieux avec soi-même prenait
tellement plus beau comme humain qu'est
ce qu'on se souhaite pour 2021
en terminant en 2021 je vous transmets
le plus beau souhaitons méfaits dans une
activité avec des des gens avec le
travail de rue que la coalition travail
de recherche beaupuy un homme qui
m'avait écrit sur un petit bout de
papier
je te souhaite tout le bien qu'ils
pensent de moi et c'est ce que je vous
souhaite tout le bien que je pense de
vous voilà c'est fait sk lors david
goudreault n'a de vous lire encore puis
je vous dis merci parce que vous toucher
beaucoup de monde
merci de continuer à regarder des gens
différents qui sont plus poké autour de
nous jeter et qu'ils sont au moins de
faire un compense l'événement hydro
merci merci beaucoup